- He's an American internet
entrepreneur and blogger.
His first company was part of the
dot-com era in New York.
He has a net worth of
twenty million dollars.
He's Jason Calacanis,
and here are his top
ten rules for success.
- Things should be different this way,
and I see the world differently.
I wanted to get to this.
I want things to function
the way I think they should.
It's so hard to make that actually happen
that most people never do the first step
which is trying, you know?
And that's ninety-nine
percent and one percent.
Ninety-nine percent of people,
everybody knows that
things should be better.
Everybody's got ideas of
how to make things better,
I mean, ideas are very
easy. They're a commodity.
There's really not much value in ideas.
Really, the person who says
I'm going to take that idea and
really try to make it
actually manifest itself
into a product or service
that people can consume and engage with
and fall in love with.
That's entrepreneurship.
That's the difference.
I've always loved technology
and building things
and building products.
And I'm twenty years into my career.
And sure I don't need to work anymore.
I got lucky on a couple of projects
to make a little bit of
money, and that's nice,
but I love building teams,
I love building products,
I love building brands themselves.
So I love the act of
creating a brand like Launch,
that means something to people,
or Inside.com where people saying
like you did, oh, you did Engadget.
So for me I just love the
act of creating a brand
and maybe hopefully doing
something innovative.
And I think on my best
day I'm able to do that,
and on an average day maybe not so much.
The expectation from where I came from,
and listen, I didn't come from the slums
in Bangladesh or something,
so I don't want to overemphasize it.
But the expectation was I would be a cop.
- [Female Interviewer] Mm-hmm.
- So I took the policeman's test,
when I was seventeen or eighteen years old
with my little brother Josh.
And he wound up going into the police,
and I would up going to Fordham.
But at the time, my dad
had had his restaurant
repossessed by the federal agents
for not paying his taxes.
- [Female Interviewer] Mm-hmm.
- So they came with
shotguns that summer in 1988
and they closed his place down.
And that was the most
traumatic moment of my life.
It probably is the second most traumatic
moment of my life after 9/11.
When that happened that
changed everything about me
as a person.
To see your dad have his restaurant taken,
even talking about it now
as a forty-two year old.
And I just thought to myself,
wow, he lost everything.
And he never recovered from it.
That was the end of his
entrepreneurial career.
I said to myself, I'm never
going to fail at business.
No matter what it takes I'll win.
Cause I'm never going to
let the feds take my place.
He went $100,000 in debt,
and tax evasion and all that stuff.
It was very scary,
but I had no money to go to college.
So I had to work three jobs
and go to school at night at Fordham.
I learned a work ethic that I think
made me who I am today.
I'm a very hard worker.
I'm not the smartest kid in the class.
Just in terms of being
clever and having hustle,
I think my career proves I'll
get it done no matter what.
You can't make everything
work as an entrepreneur.
It's unrealistic.
And if everything you do in
your career is a home run,
that means you're not
swinging hard enough.
You're not swinging for the fences.
You cannot win every time.
You should be failing two out of three
things you do should fail.
If you're not, you're
succeeding at everything
that means you set the benchmark too low.
I knew it was time to pivot when
Google's results started
going from ten blue links
to ten blue links with
some content at the top,
and a YouTube video, and some news.
And all the sudden I was like,
wow, that sort of was our vision,
and sort of there already.
Okay, no problem, we'll
just do something else.
You look at what work you've done.
I think the best pivots come out of
what lesson did you
learn from your failure.
What lessons did you learn
from your moderate success,
and I have to say moderate success
is much worse than failure.
- [Male Interviewer] It's
like the walking dead.
- That's the kryptonite, yeah.
If you have moderate success,
if you can get your business
to exactly the amount of
money your payroll is,
your burn is, and you just go sideways,
that's when you're truly screwed.
You're going to take
your eyes off the prize
you'll be like, well,
I'm sort of making it.
Then the business just goes like this.
That's bad.
I don't think you should expand
until you have something that works well.
So if you have something that works well
it will be easy to expand.
If it doesn't work, going
to be difficult to expand.
So I always like to do
things when they're easy.
So it will be much easier to get it done
when you actually have a working product.
So for example, if somebody here
had a working product that did really good
message boards.
- [Female Interviewer] Yeah.
- And we don't have message
boards at Mahalo yet.
If they came to me and said
we have 100,000 users, it's working.
- [Female Interviewer] Yeah.
Would you like to use our technology,
I'd say sure.
And maybe we'd buy it from them,
or do a joint venture.
- So we would be very open to that
kind of a joint venture
if they've proven it works.
- If they haven't proven it works
that makes it difficult.
Really what defined me as an entrepreneur
was I just never felt I could ever lose.
I had to win.
I could never let the
bastards take me down
like they took my dad
down. I had to fight.
And it put a fight in
me that was not human.
It was like super human fight.
Like a resiliency and a fire
that I didn't know I had.
It served me very well.
Some people go to work everyday
to put a roof over their family's head
and to put food on the table,
and there's an honor and a respect
I have for those people, obviously.
There's nothing more noble than
being able to take care of
and provide for your family.
But you can even do that with
an entrepreneurial spirit.
Mark Pincus talks about everybody,
Mark Pincus from Zynga talked
about everybody being the CEO of something
in his company.
You can be in a big company and still
have that entrepreneurial spirit
where you're thinking how to innovate,
and how to change the world,
and put a dent in it,
and try to move the human race forward.
I think that's really
what entrepreneurship is
is that you're relentless in your pursuit
of making something that
didn't exist before.
- Right.
- Try to make the world a little better.
Try to make the experience
a little better,
looking at things and saying,
if that was ten percent better,
or twenty percent better,
or two hundred percent better,
what would it look like?
And then trying to take that vision
and make it reality.
I have a very open policy to information,
so I explain every single thing I know,
because what I've learned
about leadership is
the more information you share,
the more you educate people
of every single thing you know
the more they come back
to you with other ideas
to increase your knowledge base
and the less stress there is on you.
For example, we use Google analytics
to track how the site's going.
I made every single person in the company
go through mandatory
Google analytics training.
Most people when their running a website
they don't give the Google
analytics to anybody,
cause they want to have that
proprietary information of
knowing what's going on.
- [Female Interviewer]
Keepers of the flame.
- Exactly. And people
want to keep the data,
or the sales person and they
run the sales organization
wants to keep the list of all the contacts
and only certain sales people can see
certain verticals.
You know people develop software
to keep people in an organization
from getting to information.
I always found that very bizarre.
If you trust them enough to hire them
and work with them everyday,
then just give them every
piece of information you have,
let everybody share it and
discuss it and debate it
in a very flat structure.
Don't create a lot of management.
And create discourse.
I make myself not only available
to my entire staff all the time.
I make myself available to my enemies,
my detractors, my fans. Everybody.
- [Female Interviewer]
You're very transparent.
- It's the best way to run a business,
because all you do is get ideas
and the work that is usually the
responsibility of the CEO gets sent out
to these hundreds of brains.
It's idiotic to think that you
are smarter than everybody in the world.
Sometimes when you're
in that CEO position,
or the founder position
you start to think, well,
I had the initial vision.
I'm so smart, but collective intelligence
is always going to trump
individual intelligence.
I look back at the people in my life,
and I'm just so blessed to have
so many people who've been so loyal to me
and taught me so much,
and that also I've gotten
to be a loyal friend
to them as well.
And that's really like I think
when you look at your career,
always aspire, and I'm not
saying I have succeeded,
but always aspire to be the best,
most loyal person you
can be to your friends
and develop those long term,
meaningful relationships.
It is the core of what's valuable in life.
- So you've done Silicon Alley Reporter.
- [Jason] Yup.
- And Weblogs Inc.
- And Mahalo.
- [Jason] Yup.
- And Open Angel Forum.
- [Jason] Yeah. I love creating brands.
- Crash 50. Launch.
- [Jason] Launch, yeah.
- You're a writer in your own right.
- [Jason] Sure.
- Is there any separation,
or is that all just Jason?
It's all one thing?
- I think that's all I Jason.
I used to fret over it a little bit,
and then I realized I have a
little entrepreneurial ADD.
I get excited, I have enthusiasm.
But I'm not going to try to bridle it and
put it all into one project.
If I want to do an event,
and I want to write my email newsletter,
and I want to host This Week in Startups,
and I want to be the CEO of Mahalo
and pursue education and do apps
and all this stuff, I'm
going to do everything.
I look at one of the great
entrepreneurs of our time,
not Steve Jobs, Jay-Z.
He is an amazing entrepreneur.
He is an artist who's on stage
and he is probably the
greatest rapper alive today.
In my opinion he is,
and Biggie Smalls is probably
the best that ever lived.
Rest in piece.
But Jay-Z also ran a record label
and manages other people's careers
and a clothing line and this other stuff,
and I just think those rap artists have,
and people in the hip hop space
have a very good view of the world
which is why not try everything?
Why not do a little bit of everything?
If some people think you're doing too much
that's on them. That's not on me.
When people say, what do your investors
in this company think
about you working on this?
They love the fact that I'm diverse,
they love the fact that I
get to spend a couple weeks
in the Launch conference, learn a lot,
and then parley that
into my own day to day
experience as an entrepreneur.
I just love being involved in
a lot of different things,
so I don't fret over it too much anymore.
Thank you so much for watching.
I made this video
because Matthew Hendricks
asked me to.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know
which of Jason Calacanis'
top ten rules meant the most to you.
Leave it in the comments.
I'm going to join in the discussion.
Thank you so much for watching.
Continue to believe,
and I'll see you soon.